今年31岁，
然后现在是二胎五个月，
我是远嫁，
生活在超一线城市，
我老公比我大四岁，
我是19岁，
跟他在一起的感情基础比较好，
也比较纯吧，
嗯，
他家的爸妈的条件要比我们家的好很多，
然后他爸的总资产大概有个一个小目标吧，
然后我的焦虑的是我老公已经三年没有上班了，
他很宅，
然后他应该是属于那种特别安逸现状，
现在是二胎五个月嘛，
我相当于一年也没上班，
就是现在两个人都闲在家，
然后我公公从前年开始，
一年大概给我老公100个生活费吧。
我老公偶尔给个几个几个给我，
因为每个月生活费挺高的，
每个月两个人的支出也得大几万吧，
但基本我们也不买奢侈品，
但是吃啊用了兴趣班阿姨什么的，
一年100个也差不多都花掉了，
觉得我还是比较少的，
但是他就话的很随意嘛，
就是那种有恃无恐的那种。
然后我的焦虑是我经常会很不安，
因为我的老公一点工作都没有，
话他顺口，
我有时候对我老公表达一下对未来的焦虑，
他都觉得我日子过得不知足，
觉得哎呀，
现在有没少你吃喝的，
这时候他那个挺好的，
我还特焦虑，
还特别想干嘛，
他觉得没法理解，
我经常焦虑是觉得因为夫妻俩就能走到最后的，
最后的概率也就50%嘛，
对吧，
然后我在想，
如果万一有人败了怎么办呢？
而且果是原价这边完全是为了他来的这个地方。
然后。
自己娘家也没有任何的支撑，
这几年大的吧，
确实也懒了很多，
就是那个生活的那个压力的那个劲儿也小了，
觉得肯定也是有对我那个老公有影响的，
就是也挺安逸的吧，
但是我还是时不时会很焦虑，
挺如此嘛，
对，
独此我跟你讲啊，
姑娘啊，
可能就是直播间有很多人都没有办法理解你现在这种呃困顿，
因为他们觉得你一年有公公给的100万的这样一个生活费啊，
不用愁志，
不用愁船，
你怎么会困顿呢？
其实我觉得你的困顿啊，
从我这个角度来看的话，
主要是因为两个人的这种情绪上的相互影响，
情绪上为什么你的丈夫会影响你，
我帮你分析一下，
你看这啊，
一般情况下特别优秀特别强的父母，
嗯，
养大的这个孩子呢，
你老公这种情况就是属于比较典型的，
就是他也不太积极，
也不太有拼劲儿，
他从小长大的过程当中，
可能爸爸妈妈工作也很忙啊，
又出差啊，
或者是又开会啊，
又加班啊什么的，
对他的关注是比较少的，
给他的鼓励是比较少的，
所以你的老公他自己本身心里面还住着一个小孩，
这个小孩儿就是属于没有长大，
所以你要求说他特别有同理心，
特别有责任，
特别有担当，
能够担当起一个家庭的这样一个担子的话。
他其实担不起来，
就为你老公他是担不起来的，
如果说现在这个状态下啊，
就是公公能每个月给100万的这样一个生活费，
家里面能够衣食无忧，
能有这么好的生活品质，
你就应该放弃对你老公的这种期待，
放弃你老公能什么时候能成长了，
没有责任了，
有担当了，
能够成为家里面的支柱了，
能够给你和孩子带来安全感了，
不会的，
很难的，
他可能这辈子就是这样了，
他内在的那个小孩儿，
就跟当初他爸爸妈妈去开会了，
把他一个人扔在家里啊，
或者爸爸妈妈出差了，
现在还是那样一个内在的小孩儿，
但反过来想，
你的老公已经算是所有的富二代里面，
没有成长起来的这样一个内在小孩的人里面，
你老公已经算是不错了，
因为他没有什么不良的嗜好，
没有什么性格偏执，
没有什么非常坏的人格，
如果你老公他没有成长为那种干坏事儿的，
没有长为那种有什么不良嗜好的，
他就是懒一点儿，
他就是愿意在家宅着，
愿意带孩子，
我认为他已经算是很好了，
不拖后腿了，
他就他这种特别想证明自己实力的富二代父母，
就是干坏事儿，
就是干尽坏事儿啊，
西大爸爸妈妈的注意力要么就是老想创业，
老想投资，
老想干个什么项目，
比爸爸妈妈干的事业还大啊，
回回亏，
把家底都亏出去了，
你知道吧，
那爸妈也。
已经认准了这一点，
已经知道自己的孩子是属于那种支棱不起来的，
担当不起来的，
所以人家爸妈就想了，
我一个月一个月10万块钱，
我一年100万，
我就养着你们就得了，
我就挺焦虑的，
就是怕有爸妈托底，
那我啥也没有，
你未来的方向就是一定是培养孩子跟公公婆婆，
尤其是跟公公的这种情感链接，
说句难听点的话，
大号练废了，
让公公来练小号，
你是小号的亲妈，
你看过那个叫什么清朝的历史吗？
看过清朝的历史你就会发现一个问题，
嗯，
康熙当时想传位给谁的时候，
他主要看的是谁家孩子有出息，
你知道吧？
他就看到老四，
老四的孩子就是乾隆，
他就看这个乾隆聪明可爱，
对吧，
有慧根他就愿意带在身边培养，
而你现在需要做的最重要的事情就是啊，
让孩子跟爷爷有感情，
让孩子能够得到爷爷的重视，
在这种情况下，
爷爷他再怎么怎么样，
他也不舍得他自己的孙子心理不健康吧，
不舍得自己的孙子没有妈妈吧，
你理解这个意思吧，
当你认识到你的老公，
他就是一个没有担当的，
他就是喜欢宅在家里的，
他就是不愿意去面对外面的世界的。
好，
我接纳他，
我也不去鼓励他，
我也不去说让他非得在外面去找工作，
去受气，
我接纳了他。
那不就没有矛盾了吗？
我是不是应该出去上个班，
看你怎么开心怎么来啊，
姐妹啊，
我告诉你啊，
如果家里面有一个亿的资产的人啊，
人家不上班也是人家的选择，
为什么有一个亿资产意味着被动收入的话，
3~500万打底，
你们一年就花个100万，
就是你们连被动收入我都花不完，
就是我公婆的被动收入肯定是有，
但是我是说我跟我老公，
就是我是不是应该去上班，
我觉得你应该是把这两个孩子啊培养的懂礼貌，
有感恩之心，
这个比你上班划算，
你要只要把这两个孩子培养的懂礼貌，
有恩之心的话，
爷爷奶奶他遗产不都是他们的嘛，
就他们仨嘛，
你就哪怕你一分沾不着的话，
是不是你这俩孩子也占了爱昧江山，
是，
我就想着我们俩都不上班，
就不知道往后走，
以后会发生什么，
你们需要做的是要懂理财，
懂用钱生钱的这些东西，
然后要防诈骗，
然后不要有什么野心，
这一辈子就是顺风顺水的过了这这些奶奶不上班，
对呀，
你一个月你上班，
你朝九晚五的，
你挣那2万块钱，
你还不如好好的把爷爷奶奶哄好了，
随随便便给孩搞个信托，
给孩子搞点什么那个保险，
整点什么存款，
都比你一个月挣2万块钱强多了，
我知道我就是个人是觉得就是上班是就是挣个钱，
其实虽然不多，
但。
我在想，
因为我们两个天天呆在家很费，
你知道吗？
你知道不上班的人脑子都是，
你可以不想子，
我们两个的脑子是都是浆糊，
最后我就话几遍啊，
这事儿特好，
你们两个人都蠢，
两个人脑子里面都是浆糊，
但凡你稍微学点什么理财呀，
稍微学点什么怎么保护财产啊，
反诈骗的知识啊，
那你就占上风了，
没准将来就一管钱了。
你现在需要做的是让爷爷奶奶相信，
你这辈子就想踏踏实实跟他儿子过日子，
你这辈子就想带好他的孙子孙女儿，
你这辈子就想给他们家做贡献，
你不要让爷爷奶奶觉得你还有什么野心，
还想出去上班，
还想出去挣钱，
还想出去搞项目，
为什么有钱人最怕这种儿媳妇儿，
因为他儿子太弱了。
说句难听点的话，
你要是能力太强，
你就变成武则天了，
他就得想我得换个儿媳妇儿了，
那其实他爸之前说她认可我，
就是觉得我其实之前就是挺努力，
挺有上进心的，
你努力和有上进心的前提条件一定是得对他儿子一心一意，
你不能在他爸妈面前表现的出，
这也不满意，
那也不喜欢，
我觉得不能没有任何也好，
我在他爸妈面前还是没有任何的那个不悦的，
好好保重自己的身体，
第一，
不要希望于你的老公会改变，
第二，
不要寄希望你老公会变得强大，
有责任，
有担当，
第三，
不要劝他，
不要劝他上进，
不要。
擅长找工作，
第4，
你要对自己好一点，
该给自己补点啥补点儿啥，
自己产后的时候该报班啊健身啊什么的，
你要对自己好一点，
你对自己好一点，
你每天心情高高兴兴的，
你也反过来会影响到你的老公，
会让他觉得生活开开心心的就挺好挺知足的啊。
老婆孩子热炕头，
两个健康的宝宝，
我老婆也不再骂我了，
也不再唠叨我了，
我老婆自己每天心情也挺好的，
好你俩这日子我告诉你就是神仙般的日子，
等哪天啊，
爷爷奶腿一根儿，
留个一个小目标，
你们俩就别想什么搞什么大投资啊，
就整点什么固定的什么存款呀，
四个点呀，
整点什么那个国债呀，
整点什么这些东西啊，
就是保本啊，
别整什么大的啊，
就整点保本的，
你俩就吃点利息，
带着孩子游山玩水的，
这一辈子就是这么一眨眼就过去了，
就是我觉得有时候自己没有自己的收入，
可能觉得就不踏实吧，
你把孩子培养好，
你把公公婆婆哄得开心，
然后得到的，
那也叫个人能力的展现，
也是一种收入，
你不要觉得收入一定是去端盘子洗碗，
一定是出卖劳动，
有的时候我们人情世故到位，
情商到位，
她也是收入5，
没事儿，
你得老跟公公婆婆说，
上辈子到底是拯救了什么银河系啊，
遇到这么好的公。
公婆婆，
哎呀，
我到底哪里修来的福气啊，
能嫁到这样好的家庭，
这姑娘可能是现在因为是怀二胎嘛，
她没有安全感，
这是很正常的，
这个是激素导致的，
或者说基因自带的一种程序。
女人在怀孕过程当中是特别需要安全感，
它需要一个确定的，
比如这个男人能够照顾好我，
这个男人能给家庭带来足够的粮食，
能不让我和孩子饿着，
不让我和孩子冻着，
不让我和孩子遇到什么危险，
这个是很正常的。
我希望我直播间的其他的所有人也要从一个设身处地的，
他怀着孕5个月，
而自己又不挣钱，
老公也不挣钱，
从他的这个角度来看待这个问题的时候，
他就是会没有安全感的。
那龙飞姐，
我存在的价值是什么？
我让他跳脱那个小小的画面，
来到一个大的这样一个视野下，
能够看到一幅大的画面，
能够看到一幅大的画面就是把爷爷奶奶他们的财富哎，
都看到这个画面里头，
你不光有老公，
你还有两个孩子，
还有爷爷奶奶，
当我们站在一个大的画面来看的时候，
这种安全系数就不一样了，
我需要做的是什么对吧？
我只要跟我老公感情维系好，
让他在家里面的时候高高兴兴的，
不要让他有压迫感，
不要让他有想逃离我的那种感受，
好，
我和我老公之间的关系就解决了。
然后就是我和孩子，
我毕竟是这俩孩子是我亲生的，
对不对啊，
毕竟爷爷奶奶只要我不犯什么大错，
我没有什么过分的要求，
我没有让爷爷奶奶感觉到威胁的那种状态的话，
爷爷奶奶不可能上来就说把亲妈踢出门吧，
为了这俩孙子也不可能把亲妈都踢门了嘛，
对不对？
好，
那我需要做的就是什么，
就是让爷爷奶奶感受到我踏踏实实带孩子，
我踏踏实实跟女儿子过日子，
对吧？
我又没有什么野心，
我也不想挣什么大钱，
我觉得现在日子就挺好的，
让爷爷奶奶感受感受到你是踏踏实实过日子，
没有野心的，
很感恩的，
爷爷奶奶他也就放心了，
哎，
就这意思。